hello i'm patton oswalt and i'm going
undercover on the internet this is
actually me Twitter how many TV shows
are you all are you taking jobs from not
Australian actors right now technically
I am on four television programs
five if you count the semi recurring on
agents of shield am I taking jobs from
hot Australian actors considering the
two of the jobs I have were voice over
jobs I'm going to say yes because no one
crushes the voice-over world better than
hot Australians and their American
accents posted is patent short for
anything Oh Randy take a look I'm short
for everything
good cuz random question when you grew
up in Virginia were you a skins fan yes
I was a skins fan if you're referring to
the leathery skin on the bodies of
trolls in the Dungeons & Dragons second
edition so many of which I fought with
my dwarf character fifth level fighter
with its a plus three acts of cutting so
was I skins fan yes
next answers calm where does patton
oswalt live well the answer to that is
easy in your mind
what ethnicity is patton oswalt well I'm
white no sorry
I'm pasty white submit it what was the
answer to a question about Patton Oswalt
on Jeopardy it was a two hundred dollar
Jeff I only got the $200 one oh it was a
two hundred our Jeopardy question from
the category the performer Wednesday
January 26 2011 the clue was patton
oswalt cooked up the voiceover I mean
the rodent in this 2007 film and the
answer of course was Bad Lieutenant
darin harvey keitel that was a very dark
period in my life more Twitter when you
were a wedding DJ what was your go-to
song to spend well unfortunately my
go-to song to spin was almost paradise
which was the lead singer from loverboy
and one of the women from heart and my
god Virginia rednecks love that song I
don't know what it is but it's catnip
catnip for rednecks
why did Patton Oswalt's Netflix special
make me cry it could be one of two
things one because I was courageous
enough to try to reach some new
emotional deaths and expose myself for
my inner being on camera
r2 you may have sat on your scrotum
Bobby Miller jr. asks when will you
share BTS pics of you in your motion
capture suit
hashtag Z hat me well Bobby Miller jr. I
would be happy to share those
photographs unfortunately Bobby Miller
senior got a little aggressive asking
for motion capture pictures from the
king of queens yeah that's right I did
that whole show motion capture there was
an injunction and a restraining order so
right now I'm sorry if I'm a little
gun-shy but I don't think I can share
those with you and blame your dad for
that officially on the Internet
when did patton oswalt become the Bears
offensive coordinator asks Mason Forrest
heylook work his work reddit
someone wrote my baby is patton oswalt
look a lot of babies look like me I've
learned to live with that and there are
certain fetish groups which I do very
very well with so I'm not complaining
what am I looking at I love Patton and
that level is T 3 K I'm seriously don't
know what is happening I am hoping that
is what I think it might be I'm assuming
this person has died they seemed very
frightened and confused and assumed
after this they went and walked into
traffic
captain ham pockets which we all know is
Joe Biden Wikipedia Oswald was born
January 27 1969 in Portsmouth Virginia
he was named after General George as
Patton and then very quickly broke the
world's record for a most disappointed
father he is a 1987 graduate abroad run
High School Ashburn Virginia was
initiated into the Alpha Theta chapter
of the Phi Kappa Tau fraternity insert
requiem for his liver you may not
believe it but it's actually me I am DB
his favorite movie is six-pack it's not
I think some troll added that and I saw
that years ago I'm like I'm never
changing that I know what that is that's
my Brown Eminem's thing if someone has
read that it means that they just did
the most basic research on me and
there's a [ __ ] interviewer so I'm never
changing that I've never seen six-pack
I'm vaguely aware I think Kenny Rogers
isn't that thing it's not my favorite
movie my god was considered for the role
of Albert Brennaman in hitch I didn't
know that I would have taken that role
women he considered me why don't you
tell me you idiots what a dumb man a
second but I would love to act with Will
Smith what are you nuts
I was considered hey thanks a lot thanks
for the late notice guys
what could the ad here trivialize let me
see recently found out he's allergic to
gluten explains a lot of the coughing
and hacking I did all through my 30s and
40s was inducted into the Harvard
Lampoon Oh Bo Diddley once yelled at him
in Wichita Kansas that really happened I
saw Bo Diddley and then after the show
all these hot women are going up with
sage to get their pictures taken and me
being a dummy like I'll go up on stage
to any term you just get off the stage
and you know what I deserved it submit
more Wikipedia Oswald first began
performing stand-up comedy in the late
or early 90s late 80s by his own
reckoning by his own reckoning I know
the exact date Wikipedia I've said it in
a million interviews my own reckoning
what did I do suffer a head injury
I started July 18th 1988 I'm not some
weird Norse poet by my reckoning it was
a stormy night I was done no July 18th
1988 by my own reckoning good lord this
is a Cormac MacCarthy novel after
writing for Mad TV and starring in his
own 1996 comedy special for HBO he went
on to garner notable roles in film and
television shows he has also appeared in
smaller roles in such films as Magnolia
and 22 Jump Street and by small roles we
mean literally one scene the caterer had
a bigger role in those movies than I did
even more Twitter how can you possibly
look exactly the same 41 years later I
want to just be glib and say pomegranate
juice but the darker answer and the
truth is that we have fallen into an
inverted time on where none of us is
actually aging and then I want me to go
look in the mirror and be prepared for a
shock that's right entropy is dead we
are all frozen in a peak moment of
horror and hopelessness oh hey watch ap
bio Thursdays at 9:30 on NBC I had a
dream Patton Oswalt got arrested for
breaking with a Paul McCartney's house
charging at him naked this was a dream
right well yours was a dream but the
reality where I charged at Richard Marx
naked that was quite a different story
Ryan Rd which may I say is an anagram
for Hitler Youth with hangin oh no it's
not
sorry it's not why did patton oswalt
voice act in Minecraft story mode right
now there's a certain explosion going on
in the world of video games and because
of that there is a boomtown aspect to it
where they are overpaying any voice
actor who says yes way beyond their
abilities or paygrade Circe's actually
me Warren could patton oswalt Star Wars
vision
what they're referring to here is a
impromptu ramp in which I combine Marvel
Universe's the DC universes Fantastic
Four x-men Star Trek and then the Greek
gods who clash the Titans because Disney
has now bought up all of the Fox stuff
technically they could combine all of
these different properties into one
massive mega thing however Clash of the
Titans is still owned by Universal so no
my vision could not happen but I do
think an alternate vision could happen
with Star Wars universes the Marvel
Universe's Star Trek universes and The
Blues Brothers
close enough more reddit i mean my god
this is a poster that the people that
Entertainment Weekly put together based
on my vision I will say they literally
put every single element that spewed out
of my skull into this they put Moon
Knight in there they put robot Chewbacca
that's the x-men ship and I even have
Amy Poehler's line the female parts a
little underwritten mud thank you aw I
will always love you
I wonder if Patton plays Phil Collins at
home when I have kids the most recent CD
that I will own Phil Collins no jacket
required that'll be the most recent CD I
own
unfortunately I kind of didn't hold up
to that promise I started off my
daughter listening to stuff like the
Ramones and the Beatles and the Pixies
girly stones and Bowie I've basically
raised an eight-year-old with the
musical taste of a 48 year old so I've
destroyed our life